welcome back we've got a full couch
y'all tony gonzales josh brolin and best
selling
we've been talking about my stranger
reads initiative which promotes reading
something my next guest is deeply
passionate about she's an education
activist an advocate and author and in
2014 she became the youngest recipient
of the nobel peace prize putting my
sports emmys to shame
dialed in from london please welcome
malala yousafzai
hello
okay so malala like what was the first
book you read that made you a lifelong
reader
my favorite book has been the alchemist
it was one of the first books i read
when i was a little kid in pakistan and
a lot of students were limited to school
textbooks because they did not have
enough libraries or they were not
encouraged to read books outside their
school textbooks so i was very lucky
that i was gifted this book and since
then i have become an avid reader and i
really am uh considering myself
fortunate to have access to libraries
and books now and and to be able to read
that's amazing like reading something
that cool like so young so you're you're
a tireless advocate for girls education
so what are some of the biggest
challenges that you you think we face
right now
there are 130 million girls out of
school and the recent events including
the pandemic and climate related changes
is making it worse uh more girls are at
risk of losing their education and i
think something that really needs our
attention right now is what's happening
in afghanistan afghanistan is the only
country in the world where adolescent
girls are forbidden from having access
to education
it is unimaginable like why can't a girl
go to school why can't she have the
right to be able to read and write so it
must wake us up and uh and and challenge
us to speak out women in afghanistan are
on the streets they are protesting for
their right to have access to education
to have access to the right to work uh
so
you know i know that i receive so much
support around the world because i was
one of those girls
i and i shared my story and people heard
my story but i want to remind everyone
that the story of malala is not unique
it is the story of millions of girls who
need our attention who need our support
it's so sad that there's so there's so
many out there
you y'all have a connection so you've
never met malala but you you i'm so star
struck right now and i don't ever get
star struck and i so appreciate who you
are i did have a back and forth with
your father who wrote an introduction
for steve mccurry's uh
photographs he just did a book and he's
a friend of mine so i ended up actually
having an instagram back and forth with
your dad
yeah and i loved it there was any
connection with you because i have three
girls and what you do means the world
[Applause]
oh man that's so cool it was such a
random thing that we found out we were
like ha what i know yeah
me and dad are hanging out we're bros
yes yeah
you're instagram bros so so malala
you've also found a new way to advocate
for reading and education so can you
tell us about it yes i'm part of uh
literati and i am
their chief education advisor and
we know that not all children have
access to
books and resources of education and
this pandemic has made it worse for many
children so i'm working with literati as
this
advisor and i am here to ensure that
children especially in underserved
communities can have access to books
that inspire them
so literati has made this commitment to
donate
100 000 books to those kids and i uh
hope that you know more kids can get
inspired to believe in themselves and
step up for changing uh their
communities uh and following the dreams
that they believe in absolutely that's
so cool
do y'all remember a book that just
completely changed you kind of opened
your eyes mine was matilda i just have
been like the fourth grade i thought it
was magical and it made me love reading
so was there anything like that for
y'all i had one i have yeah it was
called seven daughters and seven sons it
was by barbara cohen and by ija lovejoy
i read it in fourth grade and i checked
it out so much that at the end of the
year i was like can i buy this and my
librarian was like you could lose it
i know i like she was so sweet
and and it was it was the first time i
said it's damaged i know it's like we
don't know where it went um
it was it was the first time i had seen
arabic words in a book the first time i
saw a brown girl as like the hero and it
made me know that i was here that we
were here we were present we we were we
have stories we have stories and that
they are worth sharing and so it was
such a special book for me and i i still
you know i still haven't totally made an
impact on the trajectory of my life yeah
absolutely and i still keep it in a
place of honor on my shelf and like it's
it's just in a place of honor i'm just
stealing that yeah people are gonna grow
myself like it's in a place of honor
exactly
high up on the shelf i'm yeah i'm
stealing it i'm gonna say i made it up
i'm just kidding totally i'll give you
credit um did y'all have a book like
that
um yeah actually i'm a little bit later
to the game of reading uh which i think
is hopefully people have to go look it's
never too late but my uh going into my
second uh third year in the nfl my
second year in the nfl i dropped i led
the nfl and dropped passes
and so i got benched twice and my
brother sent me this book by vince
lombardi called when pride mattered and
it was the first book that i had ever
read from beginning uh to the end that
wasn't required reading and the whole i
don't know if most people don't know who
vince lombardi is or if you do he's one
of the greatest coaches of all time in
the nfl it's what the super bowl trophy
is named after no i knew because i have
sports emmys yeah you got the sports in
me so you so you know you know i have
knowledge that i can drop like that all
the time but but that book
that book changed my life where i read
that book and i got so excited like the
greatest moment in a man's life is when
he lies totally exhausted on the
battlefield glorious and off of that i
went out and i started reading of all
these other books by coaches and
biographies and then since then i mean
i'm an avid reader it's like once you
find something that really piques your
interest then it just takes off yeah and
you see what what reading can do how it
can change your life and the people's
lives around you it's such a domino
effect it's not just you yeah that's
learning it's you learning and then
spreading that information to everybody
else it's a cool thing absolutely
absolutely and expanding your kids
vocabulary like with children like
that's what we read all the time did you
have one just reading is a huge thing in
my household and it always has been but
i remember you know growing up on a
ranch i think i just said it to you
growing up on a ranch you're out in the
middle of nowhere you're feeding 65
horses every day and then i read uh ray
bradbury's fahrenheit 451 which is about
censorship and all that ironically yeah
and it just exploded at my brain i mean
i was just you see through the hue of
what you're reading instead of having to
deal with the sour reality of what
you're dealing with which is oh i'm
doing this thing every day and it's
monotonous and i'm out in the middle of
nowhere and then suddenly there's color
everywhere and just reading is
everything yes it's wonderful
everywhere you're stealing that too
um i'm a klepto um so as you know our
stranger reads initiative is all about
sharing books with strangers so malala i
was curious
if you wanted to share a book with me
and i would share one of my favorites
with you today of course i would love to
share a book with you last year my
literary book club
had this memoir called after shocks by a
debut author
nadia oyusu and
she is abandoned by her mother at age 2
and orphaned by her you know when her
father dies at age 13 and this is about
how this young woman has to create her
own home and her own place in the world
and the strength and courage it takes to
do that and i think it would really
resonate with you and all your viewers
kelly so i hope you would enjoy that i
love it
and i have not read it so i'm very
excited about it
i have okay
i love this book i'm about to show you i
it literally sent me on such a path um
it's called the language of flowers um
by vanessa different and it's
so so good the story is kind of similar
in the sense that the the female
character the lead in it has to like she
goes through like 30 foster homes it's
just like kind of just keeps hitting
hurdles you know hurdle after hurdle and
and it just kind of tells her this she's
very um much introverted and she starts
to speak um
via flowers like she makes these
incredible and they all every flower has
a meaning and it kind of goes back to
victorian times which i didn't know and
that's how they communicated especially
lovers um with flour i know exciting now
it got bridgerton y'all um
but no it's it's the language of flowers
and it's and it's just an amazing thing
how she ends up communicating it she
finds it's her like kind of vessel of
communicating then it ends up kind of
opening her up to relationships and like
different you know things that she
wouldn't have done but it's so
interesting and i had no idea that there
was like a language with flowers and now
i'm obsessed and i send a case to
everyone
and they all have meaning
it's like it's very it's very very cool
and it was just a different kind of
novel that i'd never read so anyway i
hope you like it
i would love to read it and for me the
highlight of this show is meeting all of
you and also
i love your votes kelly i love them oh
thank you thank you so much
thank you everybody
[Music]
you